what we're supposed to be a peaceful
march descends into chaos and
destruction on the streets of Hong Kong
a small fire most likely caused by a
petrol bomb burns before it's doused by
a water cannon elsewhere police swoop in
to arrest a protester after
demonstrators ignore their warnings to
leave four hours into the protest march
police withdrew their permit for this
rally deeming this to be an illegal
assembly meaning they can take action to
clear the streets and that is exactly
what they are doing here
riot police we've got water cannon
clearing the streets of protesters as
well as the barricades that protesters
have set up crowds of protesters many
wearing gas masks had earlier used
umbrellas and bricks to block roads
police fired rounds of tear gas to
disperse the crowds the March had
started peacefully in the early
afternoon attracting tens of thousands
of people who slowly made their way
along a three and a half kilometre route
young and old they chose to spend New
Year's day much the same way Hong Kong
had spent the second half of last year
at another street demonstration among my
new year's wish for peace in Hong Kong
but that will depend on the government
and the Chinese Communist Party if they
continue to tighten their grip on Hong
Kong then these protests will continue
along the way labor union groups set up
recruitment booths and volunteers
collected donations to assist the
protest movement the crowd didn't let up
on its five demands which include an
independent investigation into
allegations of police misconduct during
the protests and the right to choose
their leaders
police stood a distance away keeping a
close watch occasionally
protesters would direct their anger at
the police the anti-government protests
in Hong Kong have gone on for nearly
seven months now and even though their
rallies and gatherings almost every day
they've reduced in intensity there's no
indication the government is willing to
make further concessions no matter what
the outcome will be we have to persist
but no one knows for how long
this will go on Florence lui al Jazeera
Hong Kong